well we've got some very sad news to
bring you uh this sunday morning we've
just heard from uh tottenham hotspurs on
their uh official twitter account that
the uh the great jimmy grieves has
passed away uh they tweeted in the last
few moments we are extremely saddened to
learn of the passing of the great jimmy
grieves we extend our deepest sympathies
to jimmy's family and friends at this
sad time it finishes with rest in peace
jimmy spurs tweeting in the last few
minutes and of course jimmy grieves
spurs his highest ever goal scorer he
scored 266 goals for them and of course
the highest ever goal scorer in the
history of english top flight football
357
goals scored by him he also scored more
hat-tricks six in total for england than
anyone else
and finished as the first division's top
scorer in six seasons of course a member
of the english football hall of fame
since he retired grieves of course went
on to a very successful career in
broadcasting didn't he working
alongside ian john on saints and saint
greavesy a hugely popular tv show ran
from 1985 to until
1992. he was also regular on itv working
on numerous sports programs a friend to
all of us here at sky as well so the
very sad news that jimmy grieves has
passed away